We mentioned Winston Churchill
with his signature cane,
drinking scotch whiskey and puffing
on a Cuban cigar in his mouth.
His downs end and his voice as
gruff and his words pointed.
This is the image of
that Hollywood portrays,
but it is a caricature of
the flesh and blood version.
So who was Winston Churchill
in Britain's darkest hour?
Churchill lead his country from the
brink of Nazi conquest by forging an
alliance with the US and Russia.
He had many critics and made
mistakes on a grand scale,
yet above all possessed and unwavering
belief in his own power to his beloved
country,
he offered his blood toil,
tears and sweat binds
the political figure.
Who's a family man,
a man of literary distinction and artist,
a great lover of pets and a tinkerer.
Yes,
Winston Churchill,
that many hobbies today on biographics,
we painted the complex
picture of the lion.
So Winston Churchill,
so winston,
who was born on November the 30th,
18,
74 into the upper echelons
of British society.
His father was Lord Randolph,
Henry Spence at Churchill,
a prominent politician,
and the third son of the seventh duke
of Marlborough Churchill's mother Jennie
Jerome was an American
beauty and socialites,
the daughter of a wealthy New York
stockbroker and finance financier.
The glamorous couple would seem
like a match made in heaven,
but they lived mostly apart
and carried on separate lives.
They also couldn't really be
bothered with the young Winston,
the very privileged of his pedigree,
Eden's afford in the kind of love and
affection that he sought from his parents.
Sadly,
throughout his life,
both father and his mother
were distance and neglectful.
Fortunately for the young Winston,
there was one adult in his
life who provided emotional
support and acted like a
mother figure.
Churchill's Natty Elizabeth Everest,
William as Winston called her after a
failed attempt at saying women as a child
was hired to care for Winston
when he was one month old,
she would remain his only real friends
and confidence throughout his childhood.
When she passed away,
Churchill said of her,
she had been my dearest ends.
Most intimate friends during
the whole 20 years I've lived,
I shall never know,
such a friend to gain.
Winston was just seven years old when
he was sent away to some Georgia school.
It's got a boarding school.
It was not uncommon for schoolchildren
in upper class society to be sent away,
but his mother dropped him
off at Paddington station
alone to catch the train at
his first school.
Winston was bullied and bruised by the
headmaster who commonly birched the
students,
a form of corporal punishment that
involved striking the bottoms of boys that
misbehaved with visible scars on Winston
from the beatings and pleased from his
loving nanny.
His parents withdrew him and placed
him in the Brighton School in 18.
80 two.
Winston escapes the brutality
of his first school,
but not the lessons of
Brighton which he despised.
Winston hated the regiments
and was rebellious.
His poor academic scores and speech
impediments or less made Winston and easy
targets and subject to ridicule.
In 18,
eth winston enrolls at the Harris
school bus with a bismal entry scores he
placed at the bottom of his class that
Winston excelled in the subjects that
interest in him,
including English and history.
He also demonstrated a pro
athlete for the sport of fencing,
winning the public schools
fencing championship.
Yet the few bright spots were
overshadowed by deepest sadness.
Winston recalled in retrospect those
years for not only the least agreeable,
but also the only baron and
unhappy part of my life.
Winston Churchill nearly died from the
self imposed active provider at the age
of 18 when he jumped off a bridge,
he would later India,
three days of unconsciousness,
a ruptured kidney,
and three months in bet it happens.
When the teenager was playing chase with
his 12 year old brother Jack and his 14
year old cousin while
vacationing at that answer state.
According to Churchill
and his 1930 memoir,
he was trapped on a rustic bridge with
brother at one ends and cousin and the
other.
Rather than be captured,
Churchill leaped from the bridge
aiming for a pine tree to slide down.
You greatly misjudged the distance and
fell the full height onto hard grounds.
Churchill was extremely lucky to survive,
but it wouldn't be his
last brush with death.
Indeed during his life,
Churchill was prone to accidents including
crashing a plane while learning to
fly it,
nearly drowning in a lake,
falling several times from horses and
getting hit by a car while trying to cross
New York's Fifth Avenue
due to his poor grades as heroism pitch.
Churchill's only chance at a
career was through the army.
It took Churchill three attempts to pass
the exam for the royal military college
at Sandhurst.
Churchill described taking the portion
of the exam and leaving it completely
blank except for his name and
number of blot and several smudges.
His father had wanted him
to be in the infantry,
but his scores were not
good enough for the cavalry.
The new training at
Santa excited Churchill,
and over the next 18 months,
churchill thrived.
He recalled I was no longer
handicapped by past neglect of Latin,
French or mathematics.
We now have to learn fresh things
and we all started equal tactics,
fortification,
typography,
military law and military
fortification forms.
The entire curriculum in addition
were drill gymnastics and writing.
Churchill finished 20th out of 130,
and his graduating class,
Judge Hill craved action and
show no fear on the battlefronts.
Churchill knew that he was destined for
great things and he had to prove it to
the world,
and war provided the perfect
opportunity to do so.
Churchill served in the British army.
There are only for a short
time from 1895 to 18,
99,
and during the same time wrote a military
reports for newspapers as well as two
books.
The story of the malecon field
force and the river war in 18,
99.
Churchill stepped into politics trying
to win the election to the House of
Commons,
but he failed without hesitation.
He traveled to South Africa to cover
Britain's war with the boss and say London
postwar correspondence at the age of 25.
Churchill arrived in Cape Town with 18
bottles of Scotch and the guarantee of
$150,000 in today's money
for a four month assignments.
One day,
Churchill admitted to his brother.
There is no ambition.
I cherished suit kingly as to gain
a reputation for personal courage.
He would say to get the chance to earn
that reputation in South Africa while
covering the watch that show it was
a board of train soldiers sent on a
reconnaissance mission.
The train was suddenly ambushed by the
enemy and Churchill immediately sprung
into action under fire.
He acted like a decorated general and
ordered the soldiers with him to flee to
safety.
Most of them did,
but Churchill was captured as a prisoner
of war and sent to Pretoria Churchill's
conditions in captivity.
They could have been worse.
The bose allow prisoners
to buy cigarettes,
beer and newspapers that churchill
hated every moment of it,
feeding the opportunity for glory so that
slipping in by one night with no real
plan of how to make it out of
300 miles of enemy territory.
He made a daring escape.
A massive manhunt ensued and the fugitive
Churchill was wanted dead or alive.
He avoided capture traveling at night
and drinking water from streams and when
he could go no further,
he took a chance by knocking on a
stranger's door on the other side.
He knew not whether that'd be friend or
foe saved too by pure chance or fate.
It was an Englishman who wants it.
I felt like a drowning man
pulled out of the water chapter,
would recall the Englishman
was John Howard Cole,
mine manager who had just hill in a pitch
black mine before he could be smuggled
to safety during this
time in the mine wraps,
which actually say any
company in Brisbane,
the story of an English lord son Escaping
prison camp and humiliating the bose
was a boost to the nation.
He became a hero and to
celebrity pretty much over night
with a hero's welcome and new,
found his popularity.
Churchill ran for office
and this time in 1900,
he was elected as a member of
parliaments in the House of Commons.
This was the start of a 55 year long
political career with the highest of the
highest and the lowest of the lows.
Churchill once said,
politics is almost as exciting as
war and quite as dangerous in war.
You can only be killed once,
but in politics,
many times,
Georgia was a conservative when he
first stepped into the House of Commons,
but he repeatedly clashed with
his party on a number of issues.
Free trade was crucial in his mind,
and in 1904,
it was his party supporting terrorists
that made church or cross the floor to
the opposing liberal site.
It infuriated his fellow conservatives,
but it proved to be great timing.
The liberals to control soon after as a
newfound liberal church concerns himself
with social reforms and laid the
groundwork for the postwar welfare state
general again rapids.
We'll switch sides back
to the Conservative Party.
In 1925,
the flippant politician was
highly criticized for the
moves and he was seen as
an untrustworthy opportunist.
Churchill's greatest political failure,
though the one that
nearly ruined his career,
came in 1915.
World War One was at a stalemate along
the western France with allied troops
engaged in deadly trench warfare,
anxious to ended Britain's war cabinet,
has authorized a bold military attack.
The mastermind of the 40 year old first
lord of the Admiralty Winston Churchill.
The campaign would send troops
over 1000 miles to the east,
establishing a second front to eventually
sees Constantinople and take control
of the sea route from Europe to Russia.
The plan involved a naval attacks through
the Dardanelles Straits and then a
land invasion on the gallopinto
peninsula in modern day Turkey,
lack of intelligence and competence
and hesitation by military commanders
created the perfect storm and
the campaign went horribly wrong.
Half of the ships were lost and a blood
bath on the shores lasted nine months in
all 45,000 allied troops in 65,000
Turkish troops lost their lives right or
wrong church or bore the brunt of this
failure and it forced his resignation
from politics.
For Awhile.
Churchill,
he used this opportunity to
return to the waterfront,
to gallop and the campaign
haunted Churchill for decades.
Remember,
the Dardanelles was a favorite tunes
from political opponents throughout his
career.
A second controversy would play a
churchill for a decade and send them into
political exile.
A period known as the wilderness years.
In 1929,
a debate erupted over
self governance in India,
which was at the time under British rule,
Churchill was no doubt and imperialist
and was vehemently opposed.
He also had no love for Gandhi.
You saw him as a threat to the British
empire and went so far as to say,
Gandy should not be released on the
account of a mere threat of fasting.
We should be rid of a bad man as
an enemy of the empire if he died,
except for the most right
wing of conservatives.
Job sure was alone in his position.
Much has been written
about Winston Churchill,
the Statesman,
but what was the bulldog at home?
Who was he to his friends and his family.
When Clemency Clementine Hosea met
the 29 year old Winston in 19 Oh,
four to dance.
She wasn't impressed.
He didn't ask her to dance,
just stared and never said
one word and was very gauche.
Four years later,
they would meet again at a dinner party
and this time a romance blossomed.
The couple married in 19 oh,
eight,
and would endure 57 years
together until the winstons death.
At the age of 90,
even though clementines politics
differed from Winston's,
she was fiercely supportive and made
standing by her man and number one
priority.
She quietly advised him and was the
only person who could reprimand his
behavior.
Clementine once said she would have
loved to have been a statesman in our own
right if she had been born with
trousers rather than petticoats.
Winston was overbearing
and temperamental at times,
but he was always transparent
in his love for his wife.
Proudly Boasting to Roosevelt's.
I tell plenty,
everything on occasion the
couple would find though money.
It was a constant worry for clemens in
who was born into the aristocracy that
wound up penniless in her youth.
Winston overspends enjoyed gambling
and was in and out of debt during one
particularly passionate dispute.
Clemency famously through a
plate of spinach at our husbands,
but it missed.
She also never really forgave him for
buying the family home and money that's
chartwell doing so on the sly when
she was laid up from giving birth.
The couple had five children,
but only forward survive into adulthood.
Their third child marigolds died at the
age of two and a half from septicemia,
which is an infection of the blood.
Unfortunately for her.
This is a condition of modern day
antibiotics would easily cure clementine
shrieked and anger like an animal
immortal pain upon her daughter's death.
One year later,
the Churchill's fourth child,
Mary was born Winston.
He was delighted to have the
nursery and use again churchill.
His duties as a statesmen
often took him away from home,
but he was devoted to his family,
determined to be different
from his own parents.
He were distance and
Coles whenever he could.
He doted upon his children.
He built a tree house at the family home
and used his skills as a brick layer to
construct a little summer house for Mary.
Over 40 years at chartwell at Churchill
proudly improve the property by using
his own hands,
building ponds,
structures,
and bridges.
The traps.
Jules had a multitude of
Pat's domestic and exotic.
Churchill was an animal lover and
his whole life as a teen in 18,
91,
he even sold his bicycle to buy a
bulldog named Dodo at the family home.
And both cats and dogs as well as pigs,
fish,
butterfly,
sheeps,
horses,
and black swans.
There was even a parrot called
Charlie who was rumored to Churchill,
talked to score,
could send.
It is against Hitler and the Nazis.
Though this hasn't been proven and is
most likely a myth when not enamored with
politics and taxing as
the savior of his country.
Churchill was writing,
painting,
playing Polo,
laying bricks at the family home or
vacationing with friends in Monte Carlo or
some other exotic locale.
We shall fight on the beaches.
We shall fight on the landing grounds.
We shall fight in the
fields and in the streets.
We shall fight in the hills.
We shall never surrender if it
wasn't for Hitler and the Nazis.
Churchill may never have become
Britain's prime minister,
often losing his cabinet position.
In 1929.
Many believed Churchill's political
career was over even though he was out of
politics,
he was not out of the public eye.
He continued to write books,
speeches,
and newspaper articles and warned of
the dangers of Hitler from his time in
Cannes.
The predictions of the growing Nazi
power and as the quest for domination was
coming true,
he later wrote in his memoirs,
my warnings over the last six
years had been so numerous,
so details,
and we're now so terribly vindicated
that no one could gain Samey at the wars
outbreak.
Then prime minister Neville Chamberlain
brought Churchill back into the fray as
Britain's first lord of the Admiralty,
the same position that he held
during the first world war.
Chamberlain had tried and failed
to strike a peace deal with Hitler,
and he showed himself to be incapable
of turning the rapid tide of fascism.
Chamberlain had also lost the support
of his cabinet when British troops can
prevent the occupation of Norway.
In 1948,
chamber then resigned and Churchill took
over as prime minister at the darkest
hour.
That same day,
may the 10th Hitler invaded Holland,
Belgium and the Netherlands.
Churchill was a brilliant orator,
thanks to his mastery of words.
He inspired his countrymen to fight and
some of his speeches during the early
days of the war.
Now,
some of the most powerful in the English
language victory was the only option.
He never even considered a feat even
when the outlook looks most grim.
When France fell to the Nazis
person was alone in its fight.
Churchill knew his islands nation
could not win the war alone.
He would need the United States,
and when Germany invaded Russia,
Churchill saw an opportunity
to forge an unlikely alliance.
Britain came to Stalin's
ends and Churchill defended
the decision during this
desperate time saying no one has been a
more consistent opponents of communism
for the last 25 years.
I will unsay no word I
have spoken about it,
but all of this fades away before the
spectacle which is now unfolding the past
with its crimes.
It's follies,
its tragedies,
flashes away.
The Russian danger is that for our danger
and the danger of the United States,
just as the cause of any Russian fighting
for half and house is the cause of
free men and free peoples in every quarter
of the globe to forge the big three
alliance church who have cultivated a
friendship with the American president,
Franklin d dot Roosevelt.
This was something that would
convince him to join the war effort.
He invited himself to the White House
and arrive two weeks after the bombing of
Pearl Harbor.
The prime minister stayed three weeks,
three Christmas albums.
Well policy as welcome in
Eleanor Roosevelt's eyes,
but it was absolutely
critical to solidifying their
alliance and winning over
the Americans the tube on do they
have a daily lunches and late nights
strategizing by the time you left ftl
founds that he missed his friends and send
a note to Churchill in London,
which reds it is fun to be
in the same decade with you,
with the Americans now in the war and
the Russians fighting on the side of the
allies.
Hitler's armies were pushed back and
victory was declared on May the eighth,
19,
45 in Europe.
Three months later in the East,
Japan surrenders marking
the end of world war two.
In a surprise,
that very same year,
Churchill did not win reelection.
Following the ward,
Churchill continue to
influence world affairs.
He gave his speech on the iron and about
the USSR threats and was strongly in
favor of person's independence from
the European coal and steel community,
which was set up after the war,
so you neutralize European
competition for natural resources.
Churchill actually served
as prime minister again in
1951 and resigns at the age
of 18.
It was at this time that he
was in deteriorating health.
Churchill was intense on
leaving his mark on history,
not just through clamoring for fame and
power or placing himself at the center
of the action.
Indeed,
he would write his own story and solidify
a favorable view to be passed through
the ages at the end of world war two,
Churchill wrote as best selling series,
Second World War,
and won the Nobel Prize in literature
in Nineteen 53 and that same year,
he was knighted by Queen Elizabeth the
second in 1965 after suffering a stroke
two weeks earlier.
Winston Churchill pass from
this life until the next.
It seems.
The whole world felt the
loss and reporters remarked
that it was the end of an
era.
The queen saw to it that Churchill's
funeral was the grandest of any commoner
since 18,
52,
which was on a scale.
The fitting has position in history.
His body lay in state in Westminster
Hall for three days and nights,
and it's no fewer than 320,000 people
filed past to pay their respects.
And as we move towards
the end of this video,
let me mention something interesting.
Ten years ago,
a fifth of all British teenagers.
Polls believed Churchill to
be a fictional character.
His legends indeed may seem larger than
life and knowing them and apart from his
greatest moment on the
world stage is to grasp.
To say he was complex and
contradictory is an understatement.
We know he held himself
in the highest regards,
but Churchill also suffered
in the depths of depression.
He referred to it as his black dog.
His stubbornness courage,
grits and his brilliance with words made
an indispensable and his legacy is one
that will live on and inspire the good
fight and no doubt Joshua will continue
to be judged and analyzed through the
ages for his failed decisions and on
popular attitudes.
He was a product of the
time with an impossible job.
Statesmen are not called upon
to settle easy questions.
These often settle themselves.
It is where the balance quivers and as
the proportions are veiled in mystery
that the opportunity for weld
saving decisions presents itself.
So I really hope you enjoyed
that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put out brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and
subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on Youtube.
If you actually want to get a
notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to
the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time.
Every Monday and Thursday
won't put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch
something else right now,
stuff from the archive over
there on the race and as always,
thank you for watching.